Speaker 1: So we've been following
two things with great interest.
Number one is Tuesday's gubernatorial election
in Virginia. Very important race. It's Democrat
Terry McAuliffe against absolutely radical,
outrageous extremist Republican Glenn Youngkin.
And not only is that an important race
for Virginia keeping Virginia blue,
but it also it's at least being theorized
as important, maybe in terms of how it would
affect the politics of the area, including
neighboring West Virginia and Democratic
Senator Joe Manchin. Willingness to concede
more. Or there's always different ways in which
it's important, but it's a very important race.
Number two, we've been following the new trend.
I mean, I think at this point, it's a trend of
Republicans saying, if we don't win, it's rigged.
If we don't win, it's rigged. We saw
this with the 2020 presidential election,
and we'll look at some other examples. Republicans
are already claiming fraud in the Virginia
gubernatorial election. They're already doing it.
Fraud? Exactly. They are now saying, it sounds
like we're hearing that Democrats are already
cheating. We're going to look at a video now
of the Virginia Republican state senator Amanda
Chase. She was interviewed on Real America's voice
outside the Beltway the day before yesterday.
I believe it was. And she says Democrats are
cheating. They're already cheating, folks.
They're doing it every race now ahead of time.
Democrats are already cheating unless we win. If
we win, we won despite the cheating. If we lose,
we lost because of the cheating. Take a look.
Speaker 2: Look, I'm all about fighting for
the truth, too. And sometimes, unfortunately,
we can't always rely on the media. I wanted
to go there. I wanted to feel it. I wanted to
see it. A picture is worth a thousand words.
I know how Democrats are cheating, right?
Speaker 1: And that's already. We don't
even have any votes counted yet.
Speaker 2: Information has been
given to the Youngkin campaign.
Speaker 3: Well, they're going
to try to do it in Fairfax County. You know,
Speaker 2: I'm already getting reports today
that people are going to vote and they
have never done a mail in ballot, ever.
Speaker 1: Wow. Is that even legal?
Speaker 2: Yet when they went
to cast their ballot, they were told, No,
we've already mailed you a mail in ballot.
And so we're already looking into that.
Speaker 1: That's right. So again,
those are assertions about which there could
be multiple different explanations. It is not
evidence of cheating. It is not evidence of fraud.
And it's not evidence that it's Democrats that
are doing anything that could, even if true, that
could be happening to the same number of Democrats
and Republicans. It's three layers of nonsense.
Speaker 3: So that's why we told everybody in
Virginia vote early. So that couldn't happen.
The earlier vote, they couldn't do it.
Speaker 1: Did you notice that now its vote is
now the right is saying vote as early as you
possibly can? So this is the new thing. Right
before between the 2020 presidential and the
California gubernatorial recall, we said this is
what they're going to do all the time. They did it
with the California gubernatorial recall. Remember
when Larry Elder, the Republican candidate,
was asked the day before the election, Will you
commit to accepting the results? And he wouldn't.
We knew they were going to do it there as well.
Speaker 3: Larry Elder, the leading Republican
candidate, would not commit to accepting the
results of the election. Again, whether or not
you win or lose, will you accept the results of
the election tomorrow? Right. I think we all ought
to be looking at election integrity, no matter
whether you're a Democrat and independent or
Republican. Let's all make sure that the election
is a fair election. This all work together,
no matter what the results are, to make sure
that the results are valid. And so you want
everybody who voted should have voted. Let's
all do that together. Is that a commitment to
accept the results of the election tomorrow?
All do that together. Let's all work together
on both sides of the aisle to make sure
that the election is a fair election.
Speaker 1: And so he didn't say he would accept
the results. Donald Trump did the exact same thing
a few days earlier before the California
gubernatorial recall on Newsmax. I think
this was on Newsmax saying It's all rigged,
it's all rigged. The Democrats are cheating.
Speaker 4: Well, it's probably rigged.
They're sending out all ballots. All
the ballots are, you know, mail out mail in
ballots. In fact, I guess you even have a
case where you can make your own ballot.
Speaker 1: I made one on construction
paper with crayons.
Speaker 4: When that happens,
nobody's going to win. Except
these Democrats. So, you know,
look, they're very good. The one thing they're
good at is rigging elections. So I predict it's
a rigged election. Let's see how it turns out.
Speaker 1: So that was ahead of the California
gubernatorial recall, of course. Gavin Newsom
won by such insane numbers that it became
difficult to claim that it was actually rigged,
but they still did it. So this is the move now.
This is the move. And the first step is Terry
McAuliffe has to win Virginia. And Tuesday night,
starting at 8:00 p.m. Eastern, maybe a little bit
before I will be doing live election results of
what is happening there as well as the New Jersey
election. We've got some. Mayoral elections in
different parts of the country of consequence,
a lot of different things. That's step one.
Number two is really thinking about the long term
impact of this that they are now using. If they
didn't like the results or they predict they might
not win, it's it was rigged, it was stolen, etc.
not only because of the systemic risk
that it presents in terms of just
denouncing irrationally. The basic institutions of
democracy in the United States. But it could lead
to a sort of boy who cried wolf situation where at
a certain point they actually rig an election and
steal it. And when we pointed out they can come
in and say, Guys, we've been calling out rigged
elections for years and you never paid attention
until now because, you know they'll do it if given
that opportunity, so concerning for a number of
reasons, they're doing it in Virginia as well.